so I mean I've spoken about this for for
ages which is I do not believe Mass
layoffs are a great strategy on an
annualized basis to balance the books
you know layoffs happen in extreme
examples in extreme cases to that are
existential to save a business but the
way we use them so easily and so quickly
I think too many leaders don't realize
the damage they do or if they do realize
that they don't care the damage they do
to the culture and the trust that they
destroy simply to make the numbers work
and what's more distressing you see this
in public companies for example is mass
layoffs are announced like Disney just
laid out seven thousand people and their
stock price went up three and a half
percent like what is wrong with that and
that's because we're rewarding people
literally for managing short-term
numbers
um so so what leaders can do to avoid
the trust deficit that's that happens
when you have mass layoffs stop using
mass layouts to balance the books
that's how you that's how you fix it